what up space fame golsan here from
anime uproar and i'm very excited today
because we are going to be talking about
the new
demon slayer chapter and possibly the
last ever demonstrator chapter so stay
tuned for that if you do enjoy seeing
demon slayer content on the channel and
want to keep it coming the best thing
you could do is smash that like button
and share this video with any culture
demon slayers that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future videos
if you do like demon slayer feel free to
check out my huge demon slayer playlist
where i got videos about the hashira the
breath styles
everyone ranked from weakest to
strongest and more link in the
description
and i did react to this chapter live on
twitch as well when it dropped and i'll
be doing stuff like that
on twitch more often including demon
slayer based stuff so if you haven't be
sure to follow me there at twitch.tv
anime outpour link in the description i
hope to talk to you over there soon now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all and yes that does
include manga spoilers
so the reason i want to talk about
spoilers is because a lot of this stuff
makes a lot more
sense when you know the whole story this
chapter is a special one shot about
kyojuro
rengoku the fire pillar and one of my
favorite anime characters
so you could say that i was definitely
fired up to read this one
it starts with kyogre's father it's a
flashback that took place well before
the final chapter
even though it's classified as chapter
205.1
it's actually going to deal with one of
rengoku's earlier encounters with a
demon
but first we get some time with probably
one of the most demotivating dads in
anime
and by saying that i'm sure i'll get a
bunch of comments listing worse anime
dads but
so be it the fact remains that kyogre's
dad was never supportive of him to begin
with he told him that both he and sandra
lack
talent so they mustn't harbor
unrealistic dreams sanjuro is kyojiro
and goku's younger brother by the way
kyojiro's dad said that he the dad
himself
is the last flame pillar and that
rengoku can't take his place
that's not just not being supportive and
goku's dad is straight up telling his
son
it is impossible his dream is impossible
as we know rengoku
didn't let his father's discouraging
word stop him but we see here how he did
doubt himself
he wondered and i quote does everyone
have to be in agreement in recognizing
and praising a person's talent
for that person to pursue a dream if
someone lacks immense skill and strength
does hard work toward fulfilling that
dream and the desire to help other
people count for nothing
end quote this is without a doubt one of
the most powerful quotes and questions
in demonstrator for me its significance
should not be overlooked
we know then goku as a guy who is always
smiling and confident but that's not
because he doesn't have worries or fears
he has them but he chooses to follow his
principles anyways
and as we know even though this current
flashback and goku doesn't know yet
it is most definitely not for nothing he
wasn't naturally talented that's
actually one of my favorite things about
rengoku
he got where he was because of hard work
and not only did he go on to save
callous people
he also went on to save tundra from
akaza and that act directly led to
tundra eventually being able to defeat
muzon
and end the suffering caused by demons
so indirectly kyojiro saved the world
from demons
even though he wasn't naturally talented
and his father said he should quit
he didn't and that decision changed the
world for the better muzon would
arguably still be alive making people
suffer
if rengoku had listened to his father
and chosen to become something other
than a hashira
anyways we move on to an interaction
between rengoku and his little brother
rengoku compliments his brother for
working hard he's a complete opposite of
his discouraging father
he tells his little bro not to be
embarrassed because he was training hard
and that's wonderful with a big smile on
his face and i love to see it in goku
smile it really is heartwarming
the dude takes all the negative talk
from his dad but still manages to be
supportive and
positive with his little brother you
gotta respect that he tells his brother
to take care of the house
since he has to leave and his little
brother says he'll work hard so he can
be like kyojuro
his big brother then goku is touched by
this but it also triggers a memory he
has to pause for a moment and fully take
it in
he recalls right before he was going
through the final selection
of the demon slayer exams there was
someone who also said that he wanted to
be
strong like rengoku so that he could
protect other people too
and so that nobody would lose their
families to demons then goku was bright
smiled and wasn't sure what to say since
he wasn't a hashida or anything and then
said that they should work hard together
this crying boy was the same age as
rengoku
and held a sword broken by a demon at
the final selection
while he was shaking then goku initially
struggled to say let's work hard
together
because he had a sense of foreboding
that this dude might die
and finally at that point he felt like
he could understand maybe why his father
had grown so cold towards them perhaps
it was because his father
didn't want them to die he probably
wished that by discouraging them
he could keep them safe keep them away
from deadly demons
then goku can't be sure about this but i
feel like this is a pretty accurate
reading
of his father's behavior parents even
when they mean well
might hold you back they may try to push
you to get a quote-unquote
safe job because they don't want you to
be disappointed or hungry because you
devoted yourself to an
unorthodox job like actor artist or even
youtuber
and i can say that personally my brother
and i got plenty of pushback and
discouragement when we wanted to be
youtubers
that's just what you have to deal with
eventually the people who were
discouraging had a change of heart
after they saw that being a youtuber
wasn't a pipe dream now we have over 1
million subscribers
thanks by the way for that but we never
would have made it this far
if we allowed ourselves to stop because
of people trying to discourage us
you can't blame loved ones or parents
for wanting what they think
is the best for you but you also have to
take responsibility for your life
and decide what life you want to live
even if you fail
that's easier to live with in my opinion
than never trying and that is exactly
what rengoku decided to do
he ignored his father even if he might
have meant well and continued to pursue
his dream of helping others
we then jump back to rengoku pre-hashira
days
and he encounters a demon the demon
seemed to kill nine of ngoku's comrades
so he's no joke he even brags about
attacking five children but one seems to
be alive still so at least there's hope
for saving that one then we get another
powerful quote and goku remembers his
father always saying
that death comes for comrades with whom
you've just recently shared a laugh
it was the case this time and it's the
same in war things can change in an
instant
and it goes to show the transients of
existence that and goku often talks
about
how quick and temporary human lives are
even though that doesn't make them any
less valuable
it arguably makes them more valuable and
goku thinks to himself how awful demons
are and his face straight up looks scary
i don't know if i ever remember it
looking so
fierce he means business he starts
fighting and the demon whips out a flute
that's another thing i enjoy about demon
slayer the blood demon arts how every
demon has their own unique and
interesting powers
and we often have ones based around
music interestingly enough
then goku quickly covers his ears and
the demon summons wolves potentially
made out of blood
another aspect of his blood demon art
the demon tells rengoku
that he's at a disadvantage he can't
cover his ears and use the katana at the
same time
and so he can't fight now we gotta get
to this point in a fight to keep it
interesting rengoku seems to have no way
out
although we obviously know he does
escape here to fight another day because
this is his backstory
but right now things seem really really
bad this dude took care of his comrades
with no problem and now then goku can't
even
fight throw in blood wolves and almost
anyone would be freaking out right now
the demon notices that in goku is not
moving
and that he must have noticed if he does
move he'll collapse the demon flute
disrupts the nervous system so if
someone moves their foot their head will
move and so on
all the training warriors have done to
perfect their movements to a t
will actually work against them then
goku looks worried and the demon laughs
at how humans trained so hard
just for his flute to render all the
training useless not gonna lie this dude
is pretty op
like the flute is one thing but the
wolves definitely put him over the top
in deadliness
the wolves go to attack rengoku and he's
thinking about how life is a series of
decisions this is pretty much it in
goku's philosophy
we're not born with a fate that we can't
change
no we may never have unlimited options
or unlimited time to think but what we
choose
in that instant defines who we are great
quotes in this chapter i gotta say
as the wolves close in on ngoku the
question is
what will he decide to do he thinks
about how warriors who strive to save
other people's lives
are precious and brings this back to the
main conflict he was struggling with
in the beginning by saying that the pure
and single-minded dedication of these
warriors
is separate from their natural talent
they don't risk their lives to earn
praise
they simply feel that they must and we
see what appears to be that boy who
goku had a feeling was gonna die and
even though he seemed scared
he risked his life to protect a child
yeah maybe he died
but it was an honorable death and he
followed his moral compass
a cry from the depths of his soul and
then we get the complete 180 then goku
slices the wolves with no problem
and the demon is just like nani a
beautiful
and very epic fire tiger appears to
represent rengoku's beautiful
swordsmanship and he succeeds in
defeating the demon no problem the demon
was confused as are we probably at this
point but
he figures out that then goku hit his
ears so hard
he ruptured his eardrums so he wouldn't
hear and this was definitely
foreshadowed by the impact illustrated
in that past panel and then we figured
out that and goku's comrades didn't just
die they used sign language to indicate
the demon's ability
similarly to how jiraiy and naruto
managed to get important information to
the others
after his fight with pain even though
they died they directly helped rengoku
defeat the demon and save the child
and so even if they weren't the most
talented by trying to help anyways
they really did suggesting that it isn't
wrong to try
just because others don't agree with you
it's not a wasted life
even if you're not the most talented i
thought it was funny how the demon goes
on to say that he was gonna
join the 12 demon moons i thought it was
a nice touch
whether he was powerful enough i sort of
doubt since this is a much
weaker kyojuro but this demon was super
tricky and he definitely would have
won if rengoku found him first and not
his comrades
again even though he must be in pain
then goku smiles on hugging the saved
child
and telling her it will be alright and
once again he says thanks to his fallen
comrades she was saved
he thanks his fallen comrades for their
help for
fighting to the end to save the lives of
others and he vows to someday
become admirable like them and that's
the end and in my twitch read-through
i didn't go too much into spoilers but
again i want to say here that this is
exactly what rengoku does accomplish he
too saves tundra by sacrificing his life
in his fight against akaza
and because of that tundra is not only
able to survive but put an end to all
demons including muzon
just like he vowed he was admirable like
his fallen comrades
he was brave enough to sacrifice his
life for the lives of others as a
hashira
and because of that his will lived on
and helped tundra
set his heart ablaze too as kamina from
guren lagan would say
a real man doesn't die even if he's
killed he lives on in our hearts
and keeps inspiring us as we move
forward i feel like rengoku will
continue to have that effect on us even
though he's a fictional character
his father was wrong about him he did
have what it took to become the next
hashira
and he even had what it takes to help
save the entire world from demons the
decisions that goku made
made him one of my favorite anime
characters of all time and this chapter
did a great job of highlighting the
stuff i love about him too
and that is it for this new and possibly
last demonstrator chapter it's sad that
it might be the last one but at least we
got one more and who knows
we may get some more demon stare stories
at some point for the meantime though we
can still enjoy and get hyped about the
existing parts getting animated
like the demon train arc which will come
out in movie form in japan
october 16 2020 we will continue to
cover
demon slayer content and important
updates on this channel so stay tuned
for that
if you did enjoy this video make sure to
smash that like button and share this
video with any demonstrator fans that
you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe this
is crucial hit that notification bell
and select all or you will miss future
demonstrator videos let me know in the
comments what you thought of this
chapter and if you're excited for the
upcoming movie
i'm definitely burning up to see it pun
intended and as you wait for more demons
there you can check out my huge
demonstrator playlist
where i've covered the brett styles
hashira demon moons and much more link
in the description
and follow animeopro on twitch also
linked in the description
where i'll be streaming regularly
including about
demonslayer and i especially want to
thank the patron squad
over on patreon and here on youtube who
helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost i want to
thank the patrons of legend the ones
acknowledged by
lord tuigo himself alpha sigma and liam
thompson
and are the one-tier patrons the ones
who stand on top all clans
in grata dull world acquire respect pate
hepa jonathan king rethuan day aura
red-haired raven emperor otaku thomas
jones ken mono admirath
and christopher torley and our pro hero
to your patrons the one and only
gilgamesh who's the current most donated
overall champion of the world
nothing but a fan steelers anatoly
kazatsuki cricket xp
joel stanton very gucci jessica calefan
alicia actor
hinokami and water bonnie parks florian
joanne garcia mick sheamus deadly saint
and high school dxd73 thank you all
so much if you do enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
animeopro
link in the description if you're
interested you can also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue join
button next to the subscribe button that
you've hopefully already destroyed so
yeah you can support more content that
way if you prefer
whichever way to support us you can get
the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you